you know I can't control my facial
expressions you were looking a little
upset about some certain things and you
had told me you were coming here with a
few things to say did you say all you
wanted to say and do you feel good about
how tonight what yeah I mean I you and I
have spoke previously and I told you
that I felt a certain way about you know
some of the things that I haven't
learned since the season about Lea and
for me I didn't want to delve into it I
don't want to give any life into it like
it's already had enough life so I just
wanted to address it in a very general
way and I felt like I did that I felt
like I said my piece good who are you
glad you hash things out with and who
will you be okay never seeing again I am
so glad that I was able to speak freely
about Adam and Matt feel like America
didn't get to see their true worth
because there's such amazing guys and
there's a reason they made it that far
whether or not it played out on camera
or not I was there for it and my
relationship meant a lot to them and I'm
so glad that I was able to talk to them
about it and how I thought about and who
are you okay never sing again I mean I
think that's pretty obviously too Mario
should I put my fingers out and keep
counting no I'm just kidding Lucas
inside him in there - Wow
[Music]